buonasera a tutti
questa lastra di ghiaccio
sciogliendo con una enorme velocità e
che cosa vuol dire vuol dire che si sta
riscaldando il pianeta di fatto è questo
pianeta si riscalda perché perché noi in
questa questa volta per la prima volta
nella storia del pianeta
siamo nel po responsabili non è la prima
volta che il pianeta si scalda ci sono
stati molti motivi nella sua storia per
questa è la prima volta che noi stiamo
contribuendo pesantemente con la
combustione e come perché noi stiamo
consumando moltissima energia
normalmente energia fossile e lo stiamo
consumando ma con quale distribuzione
perché quali sono le attività che sono
responsabili di questo allora i
trasporti pesano esclusivamente il 29
per cento
poi c'è l'industria che pesa il 30 per
cento
manca una buona quota l'edilizia sono le
case le case e gli edifici dove noi
abitiamo vuol dire che l'energia la gran
parte la maggior parte la quota parte
maggiore dell'energia consumata serve a
produrre materiali da costruzione ea
mantenere le case e gli edifici dove noi
lavoriamo però esiste una energia
rinnovabile che esiste in tutto il
pianeta che si potrebbe applicare
benissimo che noi applichiamo molto poco
ma prima di dirvi quale vi devo
presentare questo signore questo signore
voi lo conoscete non l'avete mai visto
in realtà lo conoscete molto bene perché
è l'esemplare di un branco sterminato
i personaggi che si aggirano nelle
nostre città e in tutti i territori
abitiamo con questo signore io a che
fare tutti i giorni ci conosciamo molto
bene poverino lui ha cercato di
camuffarsi anche lui non è stato fatto
per volare
però adesso tutti stanno cercando di
dire che sanno volare e quindi si sta
mettendo qualche cosa di posticcio
addosso per far finta di essere anche
lui un bravo uccello che vola è un modo
per spiegare che lui è assolutamente
identico alla gran parte degli edifici
dove noi abitiamo adesso non sono solo
stati fatti effettivamente per
funzionare molto bene ne sono stati
fatti per farci stare bene però adesso
visto che c'è il riscaldamento globale
questo che dobbiamo essere più
efficienti visto che dobbiamo consumare
o meglio dobbiamo consumare meno ci
mettiamo addosso qualche cosa pannelli
fotovoltaici pannelli solari pellicole
su senza però una logica precisa perché
come fa un uccello volare un uccello
vola perché è un sistema perfetto
lui ha una serie di caratteristiche che
sono fatte tutte insieme per farlo
volare alle ossa cavea i muscoli lunghi
a le piume aerodinamico a potenza
e così lui però lui è stato inventato
per volare ma le case sono state
inventate per farci stare dentro quindi
sono state inventate per noi
e allora perché lui è stato fatto bene
per un determinato scopo e noi gli
edifici non li costruiamo per noi questo
signore invece lo conosciamo questo
signore è stato disegnato quasi che sta
dietro la moneta da un euro
e stato disegnato da leonardo da vinci
in nel 1890 circa quindi negli stessi
giorni quasi in cui veniva scoperta
l'america in contemporanea un italiano
dall'altra parte del mondo scopriva il
nuovo mondo e da questa parte del mondo
un altro italiano riscoprirà una lezione
fondamentale che poi è alla base del
rinascimento qual è la lezione la
lezione di vitruvio chi era il trueview
vitruvio era un architetto che ha
scritto un trattato importantissimo lui
non era non aveva fatto moltissime cose
nella sua vita aveva fatto aveva scritto
questa cosa che è fondamentale per la
nostra storia ha scritto il
dell'architettura la scritta per
l'imperatore augusto che voleva cambiare
completamente l'assetto dei suoi edifici
pubblici
ahimè questo trattato non è stato molto
considerato per circa 1500 anni è stato
ripreso nel rinascimento che cosa dice
dice tre cose fondamentali la prima cosa
dice se noi dobbiamo costruire degli
edifici la cosa migliore è che prendiamo
spunto da come fatto l'uomo quindi dalle
sue misure
la seconda cosa che dice è che quando
noi costruiamo un edificio dobbiamo
tener conto di tre cose la firmitas
utilitas e minustah minustah suxho ossia
la firmitas e come costruito cioè la
struttura la sua conformazione deve
essere adeguata
dobbiamo tener conto della funzione che
a questo edificio per costruire in
funzione di quello che tra cui serve e
poi venustas perché deve essere
assolutamente bello e poi ha detto una
terza cosa una cosa folgorante per la
sua semplicità ed è vi confesso
la cosa che ha informato tutta la mia
vita di architetto e che io seguo cerco
di seguire in ogni momento della mia
ha detto che l'architetto ha un ruolo
fondamentale di cura dello spazio perché
lo spazio è quel luogo dove noi stiamo
bene stiamo male ma se stiamo male noi
ci comportiamo in maniera diversa quando
stiamo male noi
abbiamo anche dei comportamenti che ci
portano e portano tutta la società ad
approvare malessere allora diciamo che
l'architetto al si deve comportare come
un medico ma cosa fa un medico un medico
semplicemente calibra quando trova
quando interviene perché c'è uno
squilibrio quindi ecco il perché della
bilancia il medico non fa altro che
rimettere equilibrio tra le varie
funzioni di un organismo complesso ma
anche l'edificio è un organismo
complesso ma l'equilibrio non è fatto
dagli stessi pesi per qualunque
variabile un equilibrio può essere per
ogni organismo diverso quindi ognuno di
noi avrà dei pesi diversi nelle proprie
caratteristiche
l'importante è che tutto sia calibrato
in maniera tale da farci stare bene e la
stessa cosa vale per gli edifici è
assolutamente identico che cosa conta
quindi per un edificio conta il dove
ed è qui che c'entra moltissimo il clima
è qui che si recupera il concetto di
firmitas perché dal 1500 in poi si si è
costruito ma con il fatto che noi con
gli impianti usiamo tantissimo l'energia
combustibile per farli andare
abbiamo perso un po il ruolo della
firmitas che cos'è il ruolo della
firmitas in architettura è il fatto di
recuperare il dove siamo e di costruire
in funzione le sue siamo quindi in
funzione del clima e funziona
dell'orientamento che ha un edificio la
sua forma è molto importante sono
importanti i materiali possibilmente
siano i materiali che abbiamo intorno
e quindi
torniamo ad essere a ragionare in
termini di passività che cos'è un
edificio passivo un edificio passivo e
non con un edificio che non consuma
eccola qui la vera energia rinnovabile
il non consumo ma noi non stiamo
inventando niente quando diciamo questo
perché si è sempre costruito così nel
mondo se andiamo a vedere ad esempio
nelle aree fredde molto fredde voi nei
vostri viaggi avrete notato dovunque
andiate che le case sono molto diverse
tutte le case che noi troviamo fino a
quando non sono stati inventati gli
impianti o per lo meno quando l'impianto
non hanno acquisito un'importanza
rilevante nell'architettura per cui gli
architetti si sono sentiti
improvvisamente liberi di spaziare nella
creatività perché tanto il funzionamento
alla famosa firmitas non era più così
importante abbiamo perso queste
competenze
allora per esempio le case in montagna
da noi sono fatte in legno perché
innanzitutto perché il legno si trova
dappertutto in montagna
ma poi perché legno ha una
caratteristica è la caratteristica di
non trasmettere velocemente la
temperatura esterna
all'interno lo stesso vale nella calotta
polare iglo con cosa son fatti con
quello che c'è in giro con blocchi di
ghiaccio il ghiaccio consente con il suo
spessore di creare un ambiente
assolutamente protetto e vi garantisco
che c'è un escursione termica tra
l'esterno all'interno che può arrivare
anche a 20 gradi in più dell'esterno le
youth le yurte per esempio anche questi
sono fatte con la lana pressata delle
pecore questa è una capanna nomade ma è
in luoghi e assolutamente freddissimi
anche la rana ha la caratteristica di
essere un coerente perfetto quindi
vediamo che nessuno di questi ha
impianti e nessuno consuma niente a
parte un fuoco all'interno ma nessuna di
queste abitazioni consuma nei posti
molto calde invece cosa che accade
accade l'inverso accade che si usa una
forte massa termica cosa significa muri
molto spessi fatti col materiale che c'è
cioè le la terra oppure pietra come i
trulli di alberobello sono hanno uno
spessore gigantesco hanno anche un metro
un metro e mezzo di spessore la pietra
non trasmette il calore che c'è
all'esterno
all'interno c'è un fresco meraviglioso
anche quando fuori c'è una calura
insopportabile
lo stesso in veneto le riconoscerete le
barchesse le barchesse sono quei le
parti laterali dove c'erano le attività
contadine hanno questi portici
profondissimi perché quando il caldo e
il sole a picco sotto viene proprio
prodotta comunque della dell'ombra e
quindi c'è un fresco ma nessuno di
questi ha degli impianti che li tengono
più freschi e più caldi andiamo in zona
tropicale
stiamo guardando le tre fasce climatiche
fondamentale in zona tropicale e le case
sono sempre molto alte e sempre
sollevate dal terreno le palafitte non
servono soltanto a stare scollati
dall'acqua servono a stare scollati
anche dal terreno perché perché in zona
tropicale non c'è tanta escursione
termica innanzitutto la temperatura
sempre a stessa tutto l'anno ma molto
spesso se ci fate caso turchi di due c'è
stato il cielo sempre un po lattiginoso
non c'è mai un sole molto forte e questo
cosa fa cosa cosa produce un'assenza
quasi assenza di ombre le ombre però si
possono produrre per che cosa servono le
ombre le ombre servono a dare una
temperatura differente al terreno quando
il terreno a una temperatura differente
l'aria a contatto col terreno più caldo
si alza lascia spazio ad un'altra aria
che subentra e prende il suo posto e
così si generano delle piccole brezze
allora in questo modo creando delle
ombre sotto le case innanzitutto non le
si mette a contatto col terreno per gli
insetti per anche
umidità delle grandi piogge ma
soprattutto si genera una ventilazione
naturale al centro vedete delle sale di
di ritrovo in moltissime capanne che si
trovano nelle culture tropicali sono
molto alte queste sale perché perché
l'aria è un gas e quindi col calore
dilata e si alza e sotto è sempre molto
più fresco
allora cosa significa questo che qui non
ci sono impianti per di raffrescamento a
nessuno di questi posti a un impianto di
condizionamento che usa energia
combustibile e quindi produrrebbe
comunque inquinamento allora che cosa
significa significa che l'uomo da sempre
ha preso spunto dalla natura
se guardiamo da vicino come sono fatte
ma dobbiamo zoomare un attimo nel
dettaglio su come sono fatte le infinite
texture delle degli oggetti che noi che
ci circondano la lana per esempio tiene
caldo ma non per il filo in sé tiene
caldo per l'aria che riesce a trattenere
tra un film e l'altro
questa è la sua caratteristica le foglie
a parte il fatto di avere un'estensione
possibile maggiore per poter produrre
clorofilla ma se vedete hanno anche
delle venature intermedie che servono
convogliare l'acqua servono ad esporsi
maggiormente alla luce solare
questa che vediamo nella nell'angolo a
destra è la pelle di un elefante un
elefante gigantesco ma comunque anche
lui ha bisogno con queste piego di
prodursi di autoprodursi dell'ombra e
poi c'è tutto il pianeta sterminato del
comportamento degli insetti di diamo le
api ma gli insetti sono un libro aperto
di scuola per come si costruisce un
alveare è un sistema perfetto sociale
oltre che architettonico ma senza
parlare delle termiti che in termitai
sono in assoluto il luogo più per
detto da un punto di vista climatico ci
sono escursioni termiche all'interno ci
sono 23 24 gradi credo di temperatura
mentre fuori può esserci qualunque
temperatura all'interno e costante corte
costante l'umidità tutto questo sapere è
un sapere del tutto naturale che noi
stiamo dimenticando e abbiamo la
possibilità di recuperare costruendo in
maniera più intelligente costruendo in
maniera passiva costruendo in maniera
tale da non avere così bisogno di
compensare i nostri errori perché sono
errori quando noi dimentichiamo la
firmitas e quindi quando noi costruiamo
non secondo luogo dove siamo ma
attiviamo un copia incolla che hai mai
adesso architettonicamente va molto di
moda
noi facciamo un errore molto importante
che ci porta a tamponare con qualcosa
che sopperisca alla non capacità
dell'edificio di essere passivo e quindi
di non aver bisogno di nessuna energia
quindi la realtà è che dobbiamo imparare
dalla natura a non consumare la natura è
fatta per non consumare l'equilibrio
perfetto è proprio su questo sono il
consumo e allora cominciamo ad
ascoltarla la natura